How's it goin' Bros, my name is Peeeewwwdeeeeepie!
Today I'm going to get a tattoo and you are coming along.
I am going to London to get it and I'm gonna walk you through the whole thing.
It should be a life changing experience.
I'm so excited, let's go!
[Dank Music]
So we're driving to London, it's about two hour drive.
I booked this appointment like three months ago or something like that.
Marzia-Yeh
I'm so excited, the artist is so cool.
I usually don't show when I get my tattoos but I thought today would be the perfect time, and if you've never gotten a tattoo before you kinda- you will get to come along and get a feel for it.
So how about that?
I gotta focus on driving.
[Laughs]
I'll see you later.
[Music]
We got one hour left to go, I wanted to talk a little bit about if you're getting a tattoo for the first time.
Things that you might wanna know.
Number one is I think finding what you want to get as a tattoo, at least the first time you get one.
It's really hard to decide.
It gets in your head and you think you have to have this reason to why you put ink on your body.
Like you have to justify it way more the first time and then the second time you get it you're like "well i just want this tatoo, I don't really care".
But I would still do a lot of research on it, personally, uh- and think about it a lot.
And I would make sure that I find a good artist, do a lot of research on the artist, and a lot of research on the art.
and eventually, you'll feel comfortable enough to do it.
[Music]
So another thing I know you're thinking about
And it's, if you never got a tattoo, and it's the pain.
Does it hurt?
Marzia: No!
Pewds: Yes!
I think it hurts but it's not unbearable pain, you can go through it,
If I can do it, anyone can do I-
Do it, I think.
Maybe the first tattoo you get, you can pick a spot where it will hurt less.
For example your arm...
Where you have a lot of fat, it won't hurt as much.
Marzia: Is that true?
Pewds: Yeah that's true.
So it won't be too bad, I promise you, you can do it.
They make it- if you have a good artist - they will make it comfortable for you and put like ointment and shit, I don't know how they do it.
I'm still gonna cry like a little baby today,
I know it.
[Music]
I feel like I have to disclaim though that... I am, oh my god.
I am by no means an expert, and you should still do your own research.
This is just based on my experience.
[Music]
We got 10 minutes left.
That was a long drive...
Oh my god.
Uhh, I'm getting a little nervous, I think that's normal.
Marzia: Yeah!
Pewds: Hahaha
I'm really excited, but like I said, I've been waiting a long time for this tattoo
'What are you getting Pewds?'
Well you're just gunna see...
Nice to find parking in London, how bout dat?
The tattoo parlor that we're going to is Sangbleu.
I've never been there but it's suppost to be really good, and the artist is called Luxiano
I'll link him in the description, if you're curious
Uh, I found this guy on Instagram
And uh... I just love his style, that's why i went with it.
And he happened to be in London this time.
Otherwise I would've just gone with Brighton, cause I hate going to London.
But yeah, we're going to eat something now if we can find a place.
I don't know.
I always decide on the spot.
This spot.
What are you doing Marzia?
Marzia, those are for kids.
Marzia, get off.
Yeah, this is cool.
Glad we did that.
Marzia: Gimmie your hand
Oh my god, you're gonna die.
Alright, that's the place, good job Marzia.
I'm not sure if we're allowed to film in there...
Probably not, in a lot of places, they don't let you.
But we're going in!
I'm nervous, I don't know why, its weird
Filling in like legal papers and stuff, very exciting...
It's a really cool shop, I really like it.
I got another tattoo coming.
Marzia: Right now?
Pewds: Yep.
Marzia: Okay.
Pewds: I want to get your opinion on this
I really like this one.
Alright, we finished, it took 2 hours, right two hours?
I feel really really good,
Marzia: Show it
Well I haven't really... Oh! You can see it, okay.
He was really nice as a tattoo artist, it was a good experience, and the shop was really nice too.
They recognized me, so they gave me a t-shirt which I appreciate, thank you very much!
We're heading back now?
Marzia: Yeah.
Ok, we're back in Brighton, and oh man that's a lot of driving.
4 hours.
In total...
It was worth it though
I'm so happy with the tattoo!
We're gonna- What are you doin'?
We're gonna clean it up now so you see how that's like.
Cause I think a lot of people don't realize that it takes a while for it to heal, so...
Very interesting, we'll see ya there.
It's been a few hours, are you ready to see something really gross?
I think I left it on a lil too much...
It didn't look like this an hour ago.
But now it really, I need to clean it.
Here's the part where...
Here's the part where you really should just listen to your tattoo artist and not me!
Cause everyone will tell you different and it's really important that you clean your tattoo properly
Dat's all I'm saying here
I'm not saying follow my-
Alright whatever, blooood.
Look at that shit, that is pretty gross.
It's important that it's kept clean, no bacteria. Treat it like an open wound
It takes a lot of time for your tattoo to heal!
Marzia: About two weeks
Pewds: Yeah!
Until then you have to keep taking care of it, cleaning it, and its kinda like part two of the tattoo I guess.
Part one is actually getting it.
I'm- I'm kinda like over careful with washing it cause I don't want to fuck up the tattoo
But it looks good, I'm happy with it, there's no damage so far
Marzia: Can you show a close up?
I'm very, very happy with it.
Clean towel.
Pat that shit.
It still hurts.
I forgot about the best thing, the cocoa butter.
Now I hate creams... But cocoa butter is dat shit.
You put some cocoa butter... Ah it smells so good
And you rub dat shit with that cocoa butter.
Aw yeah.
Marzia: Gentle now.
Pewds: You gotta cover it on!
[Indistinct ramblings about cocoa butter]
Marzia: Let me smell it.
Pewds: Smells good right?
Marzia: That's LOVELY!
Marzia: Right Puga?
Marzia (As Puga): I wanna eat Poods!
Alright done!
This has been my first day of uh... Tattoo experience
Hope you enjoyed coming along.
Was it educational? Absolutely!
Thank you for coming along, I hope you enjoyed it, and... Uh, even if you're into tattoos or not... I don't know.
But dats it for now, thanks for leaving a like, I'll see you Bros in the next video.
And Marzia thank you for being such a great camera woman.
And as always...
Stay awesome Bros!